let's give a round of applause to Team
One hi so welcome to um team one I'm
going to introduce us really quick we
have johannas we have Stefan we have
Morgan and I'm Katherine and I'm going
to start by telling you a little story
so when I found out I was accepted to
edu Design shop I started jumping up and
down because I was so excited to come
here because I had a huge problem I am
an educator been an educator for 25
years history teacher I thought fourth
grade teacher for 12 years media
literacy specialist and brand new
director of academic technology and in
my interview for my brand new job my
boss said can you build me a Fab Lab I
said fantastic all right you need to
teach
engineering and you need to get the Fab
Lab up and running I'm a history person
I have no engineering background where
do I go for resources and our company
One Vision is going to solve that
problem it's going to give me curriculum
it's going to give me training and it's
going to give me a community of
professionals and teachers to help us
move
forward awesome so when Katherine got
here we really wanted to find a way that
we could help her out as much as
possible kind of going on those three
topics you talked about curriculum uh
that support group from the community
and then the resources in your community
so our solution was to have a mobile
engineering bus that really focuses on
teacher development there's a lot of
programs out there that look at you know
um for example at my school the local
Science Museum would come and do an
experiments and it was great and
inspiring and everything but then they
left and they were gone and we forgot
because well there was nothing left to
do so what we have here is that um our
program is that we have a online site a
portal that has all this information for
Stu for teachers um then this our team
te pairs with teachers and students they
work together in professional
development they tested out here in this
section where the students and the
teachers are in action and then um when
the teachers leave they're still able to
access this information via a portal
that we've created online that um we
actually have right here running so
yep well not
really it's cool thanks so
much so two minutes of questions
judges team two can I have you come up
to this side of the room and can we have
any clarifying questions for team one
please did I hear it was a bus yeah so
the idea was that it would be an
engineering Adventure sort of truck bus
thing um but really that's just the
vehicle for our mechanism um to
transport our community of Experts of
mentors of you know Rockstar high
schoolers who would Inspire kids and
then also the people with the knowledge
to inspire teachers as well and the
bring resources cuz I'm from a place
place in Ohio that you know it's not
Boston it's not San Francisco we don't
have huge Tech we have lots of resources
but maybe people don't know so that
would be one thing that our group would
really work on is when your when our
team is there they would look around
they' talk to your community and figure
out what resources they can help pair
you up
with can you please clarify some
dissemination tactics
yeah find out about you oh well one of
the things we would do is a lot of um
Outreach we can have we would um go
conferences we would have direct mailing
to schools we would work with
professional organizations and we would
um get Partnerships we like the um
engineering society and and Outreach
that way and also because we have this
great online portal we can also share
these resources through places that
people already share things so if we
have great engineering projects put them
on instructables we find code put it on
Source Forge uh Pinterest I mean there's
lots of projects there not your own but
on these others okay and how many buses
are there like I'm just get a sense what
is the sense of scale you guys are
thinking about is there one per teacher
per school or so realistically we need
to scale up over time um the idea was
that within two we'd have one year of
kind of planning Gathering resources and
uh the idea would then be to start with
about a small group like maybe a couple
buses and try and hit a region of the
United States take for example the
Midwest or a little bit farther west
where we're not near one of those
Innovation hubs um then as information
spreads about our program um
Partnerships would be really would
increase and then we'd be able to spread
even more can you tell us about some of
the obstacles and how you'll overcome
them no obstacles
perfect without any further Ado team
two hi my name is Jay this is Kelly Amy
Roberta and
Caitlyn and we want to talk about smog
not too long ago this was not that
uncommon what made the difference that
made buildings of today much more
green which one do I have we believe it
was the lead certification that gave
people a Target to shoot for and we
ended up with a lot more green buildings
around the world
what's our problem in school today we
think a major problem is that learning
is just disconnected from students lives
face it the students are bored how can
we solve this
problem get
real or relevant empowered Active
Learning when we talk to middle school
students and that's the age group that
we're planning to Target and we say
what's important to you believe it it or
not they don't say What A over B is when
divided by x uh what they say is things
like well it's hard to get out of bed in
the morning how can we take a problem
like this and turn it into a learning
opportunity we really just need to get
real when we do we see things like this
these these students have designed a bed
that actually tips you out in the
morning how do we implement this program
uh first of all we benchmarked the best
practices there are many groups out
there that are doing great work such as
New View The Real World Learning Network
or this very design
Workshop um then we build a prototype
program we take some of these best
practices and really try to uh make it
happen in the schools and we develop the
certification we figure out what the
important criteria are and we list it
out and then we go viral um and I would
click that except that that I
can't uh vote for us get
real awesome can I get them to step over
for some questions and can I get team
three down here please I I have no idea
what you're trying to do can you can you
quickly explain that what just one
question at a time so uh we want to do
more based learning but it's not just
Project based learning it's Project
based learning where the students are
engaged in a problem in their own life
and they're using uh design principles
like we've learned here in this Workshop
to solve problems in their own life
student initiated is this the link I can
open it for you yeah uh it's complicated
I wouldn't
do changing are you proposing some
curricular changing or extra
extracurricular approach ification so
and we expect that many schools would
meet that certification by changing
their curriculum but if they wanted to
do it through an after school program
maybe that's you know it's up to them so
it's sort of setting a goal and letting
everybody figure out how to hit that
goal looking at different models that
incorporate these criteria best
practices is is there a way of
incorporating curricular material as it
already exists into uh into your program
that's an excellent question uh we
believe that a lot of the current
curricular stuff is sort of part and
parcel of this type of learning so for
example uh you know one of the examples
that we've talked about in our group is
the kids uh see that the baseball field
is practically useless in Winter um and
uh they realize hey if we put up some
wooden boards and some water and let it
freeze we could turn it into an ice
skating rink that involves engineering
that involves figuring out the uh local
zoning boards maybe they put a nice
plaque on that where they have to get a
quote uh you know from Mark Twain about
how do you get people to do your work
for you by painting the fence white um
so certainly could include a lot of the
what you normally think of as the common
core but please also be aware that it
incorporates the 21st century uh what's
it called the 21st century skills 21st
century skills aspects of the Common
Core at its
core let's keep that round of applause
going for team three
all right hello everyone we're group
three my name is Joey this is Miss Robin
of course Juan and Julianne um so we're
group three and we have a vision of the
education system where schools are
tapping into the human capital that
already exists in the community so what
we propose to create is What's called
the communa school Mentor database so
it's a place where teachers students and
professionals who are living in the
community can connect onto one digital
platform so we're going to show you how
the the website would actually work okay
so say I'm on the Communist School
website the mentor database and so I'm a
student so I'm going to press
students so um what we'll show up after
um let's say I'm really interested in
architecture I want to know how things
their build um the plumbing the
electrical wires all that so I'm going
to type in architecture here and then
it'll come up over here then I'll click
on
architecture so uh the results are a
couple people that like mentors um
professionals that um have expertise in
um Architects so I'm going to click on J
do J do her company is MVP she has 10
years of EXP experience she likes cats
and dogs so um I'm going to go connect
um via my school so yeah and so I'm a
teacher and I have to meet the Common
Core the Next Generation science
standards so to do that um in scientific
and technical writing I am going to
match up my students to a person who
could help either my gifted in taligent
or my special needs student in a format
that works mentorship or what
and I am the uh professional I the
person who's looking for ways to help
students but I really don't know what to
do and I am trying to desperately find
ways okay so I log on to the system I
put my information I talk to uh the
school district and I connect that's
it thank you thank you so much team
three that was great let me have you
scoot on over
to our panel of people in funny hats
question on the interface between um
from the students perspective is it
filtered through the teacher monitoring
yes yes and we would do background
checks on the professionals that would
do the8 weeks all of that yes and the
parent would actually get an email
what's the mechanism for uh the
professional to be to to be listed Yeah
so basically you know every every player
has is going to have their own profile
so you know we tried to represent how
each page is going to be different so
when he makes his profile he's going to
say you know how far am I willing to
travel what are my skills um what can I
bring how does he know to do that though
what's his what's the dissemination
dissemination I mean going through um
professional uh unions um lawyers
Bankers engineering associations Etc to
pull in and and all so it's really
broad-based and then it also goes to the
under employe too so the these could be
uh opportunities for those who want to
contribute and are doing other work
example Engineers like me who are in
education now who still want to teach
math and and it's also going to be on on
a face tof face level the idea is going
to be spread so imagine a a a time where
you're at a parent teacher conference
and you know someone says oh you know
Johnny's doing great and um next week
we're actually going to be starting um
Cardiology like oh you're you're a
doctor like you know you're a
cardiologist that's great like do you
mind coming into the school oh here's an
application are you on our Mentor
database you know that's sort of that's
the informal interaction that happens
sometimes in schools where you know
motivation exactly what so that connects
to the Common Core a kids want Theory to
practice right so the teachers are
providing that theory and they want to
see these things in practice and that's
where the kids come in but Al go ahead
and it's student motivation so you know
as Educators you know a very frustrating
problem is you know kids saying when am
I going to use this so the the big part
of this is saying taking the fundamental
skills that your teachers are teaching
you and and looking out and seeing okay
so what skills are these being applied
to What fields what industries and I
want to connect to those check out
net.com hi we're magma chamber uh Paul
Jonathan Victoria and Kevin
and this is Alex and he's a geometry
teacher Middle School probably and uh
he's a very good teacher but like he's
starting to lose his students and he
wants to find a way to
uh to get them more excited and fired
up this is Jane Jane is an architect who
wants to share her passion for building
and making enter make match make which
is a a great site to match up makers and
Educators so we're going to uh use our
site to uh take your profile information
and allow uh makers and Educators to
meet up online and share material with
the
world makers will be paired with
Educators based on a couple different
features so you can sort by the amount
of time you have available resources
like 3D printers uh standards like
Common Core and NextGen locality if you
want to meet up in person and skills
like your profession and stuff like
that okay so the site itself will have
have project material both videos
step-by-step instruction uh and uh and
you'll be able to actually put new
projects up as you collaborate with
other people as well as remix old
projects
uh you'll be able to also select based
on uh Common Core and NextGen curriculum
standards uh different projects that
cover different areas and then we'll
have also have ratings and reviews of of
material that's not only been created by
people and reviewing each other but also
people who have used the same material
that was created by others we also have
an opportunity to make money on the site
and make it self- sustaining by selling
uh kits for the for classroom uh
projects uh sourcing materials as also
offering sponsorships for people to
sponsor classroom activities and at the
end of each collaboration people rate
each other and they rate uh material
that they
use ultimately Alex was happy because
his students were now engaged and got to
build their dream houses and Jane is
happy because she got to share her pass
passion with younger students so there
everybody's happy big thumbs
up all right slide to the left slide
who builds who builds the pages so um uh
we we thought we would actually do some
initial content development as a lure as
a bait kind of but uh but essentially
the the Educators and the makers uh and
and skilled people working together
would create projects how are you going
to create the need for this in the
education Community the buzz the idea is
I think I think Project based education
is is very much on fire but uh but
people don't know where to start kind of
and so we give them some seed examples
and then also by uh offering guidance
for tying it into Core Curriculum
standards uh that then we're going to
people will find a way to introduce it
into their classrooms so you call it
making but now you're talking about
Project based learning is it Project
based learning is it maker education do
it it I mean it's it's a mix of both I
mean the makers and and and we were
using a broad term for makers I mean it
could be Architects it could be Crafts
People it could be jewelry makers uh it
could be it could be anything uh uh
artists uh things like that you know you
can do book binding with poetry in
English classes things like that how do
you adjust that to the current governing
structures so so I think if you allow
teachers to uh uh figure out a way to
justify it within their requirements for
covering material they have some
flexibility uh and then if they don't
then you can also offer it as as after
school activities and things like
that any other questions administrators
how would they react to to this thing
like that so uh I I talked to uh uh one
of the founders of TenMarks and one of
the things that they did is they they
they got things up through the ground
Roots the teachers start using it and
then uh eventually it gets adap it goes
from the bottom up yeah that's our
that's all right let's give team three a
round of four a round of
applause all right team five you're on
Deck let's give them a round of
applause
um hi everyone we're Team five we're
covers um we're going to do a little
role playing for you
today
um okay class today we're going to be
learning about Romeo and Juliet a
Timeless classic of two Star Cross
lovers it's going to be awesome a come
on can't we look at the website Ed Jam
Ed jams what's Ed jams it's the website
full of lessons from teachers all over
the world can you at least look at it
before we start fine I will look at Ed
jams wow this is a really cool website
there's lots of resources on here for
Romeo and Juliet I could have my
students do a rap battle that's gotten
lots of votes and stars from other
teachers or maybe my students would
really like to make a puppet show oh
that would be so cute
oh and for all my science nerds they
could do scientific inquiry of
ineffective poisons I wonder what that
entails I know let's make Romeo and
Juliet the musical that's perfect for my
students aw so you guys are going to
sing and I'll film and create a remix of
those Romeo and Juliet resources we saw
on Ed jams and then we'll post it so
other teachers and schools could use our
ideas that's great all right so Ed Jam
is an education Revolution so it'll be
an online platform where teachers
students administrators and researchers
can share best practices this empowers
teachers to mix and match what works
elsewhere all the while adapting to what
works in their local context and then
they can mix remix post it back share it
and get feedback so this creates fun and
engaging classes that are great and for
both the students and the teachers
so forget the
factory this is education as a jam
session thank you guys so much great uh
can we have teen six on
Deck so how is this different from all
the other lesson planning websites that
are out there
already so I think the idea is to just
have it more fun cuz the thing is like
we were a lot of people talk about
making things that are fun and engaging
for students how about it making it fun
and engaging for teachers so that's the
idea with like mix and match and extend
it just not from lesson plans but also
to assessment tools to delivery methods
and also have teachers and students
engaged in the process and we think with
this idea of remixing that you see a
lesson you're inspired you create
something new with your students and
then you post that back up um we'd have
to have curators who are paying
attention and kind of monitoring what's
added but that you're adding your own
content and creating an even larger
repository of content that other
teachers and students could be inspired
by as well how are you actually going to
do the evaluation of which are the best
because other lesson planning sites have
had a lot of issues with a lot of junk
and getting to the best stuff right so I
think that's a big concern of ours that
curation part and that would take a lot
of human capital and manpower to go
through that we also want to create um a
voting system so you know we had the
Stars up there and so teachers and
students that are using these sources
could vote and say like this worked
really well or this didn't work so well
and I think researchers are also really
valuable resource and partners in this
process so our major stakeholders are
not just teachers students parents but
they are also industry people
administrators and researchers and so I
think that will help how do you involve
uh
industry so uh I mean we are trying to
have these engaged methods so it can be
through field trips it can be through a
Project based learning it can be through
uh like arts or music is inside the web
sorry yeah so these methods are posted
on the web and so teachers around the
world they kind of come up with their
own methods or maybe they come up with
their own remix version and they post it
online and so this is just a platform
that's online that's accessible to
everyone and so that's where we have
researchers and Industry as well okay
thank you thank you so
much let's hear it up for Team Six w
all
right maai is a failing student he gets
in trouble for running around the room
talking out a turn falling asleep M
Makai has low self-esteem and he thinks
he's
bad so hi everyone we are flux and
fusion
and we decide to look at Why students
don't have as much fun as they gr
through school so we find that we all
know this as once we get past five we
just don't play anymore and we wanted to
resolve this by having a dedicated time
in our education system for play
specifically and through this we hope to
increase engagement over time we're
going to do this by what we call the
play lab which is a modular shared space
for everyone the school system
administrators teachers students to come
together as collaborators in exploring
New
Concepts so play can mean many things to
different people it's it might not just
be Sports and recess play is
singing play is
freedom play is debate play is exploring
the play lab offers a solution it will
increase creative engagement and
curiosity it will support organic
experiment ation and provide a safe
adaptable environment for all teachers
and students to
play and the play lab offers teachers
and students time and space to work
collaboratively across the
curriculum the space is could be a cart
or a classroom whatever kind of space
you have available it's very adaptable
it could cost nothing to whatever you
want to spend for it and the materials
can be donated by the community from
parents from businesses and everybody in
the community is welcome to be involved
for mentoring ship and coming in and
visiting and leading lessons the whole
Community is part of this project for
each
School the play lab thank
you you're stating that everyone learns
including Administration how do they
learn they learn together teachers and
administrators can go in the play lab
and actually do the things we want the
kids to do and so that they're able to
sell it to the teachers parents the
school board everyone so the teach the
administrators are involved just as much
as the kids are they say they all the
time they don't have time well they're
going to have they're going to make time
we're going to make time because this is
a time it's going to be part of it's
going to be during the school day so
there will be classes that will
incorporate a lab section that can come
here the teachers will be there
administrators you know they're they
need to interract with the students
anyway and this is one way for them to
really get to know the students that
they are that are going to be in their
school perhaps I I can ask the question
a different way teachers are already
pressed for time there's not enough time
in the school day they have to teach to
the test how are you going to get them
to take extra time to do play okay this
comes from the administrators because if
the administrators are going to value
that if they spend time um becoming
creative and learning how to engage and
the play type is going to transform over
into better testing and the play time is
tied into the curriculum as much as the
teacher or administrator wants it to be
so they it's it can be very creative in
that aspect and and I'm a school
administrator so one thing that I play I
play in the kindergarten I go to
kindergarten because they're always
active I sit down I play with them I
spend that time learning my kids and so
this will give administrators time to
learn their kids better and they can
serve the kids much better how are you
going to prevent inequity in
communities um communities that are
better resources having more access to
such
things this can be um minimal it can be
tiny just it could be recycling
materials as part of the materials it
doesn't have to be a big
old that's what I'm thinking goad a
campaign a concept a cart like a toolkit
what is it go ahead go it's a toolkit
it's a toolkit that it can be as simple
as a toolkit it can be as simple as a
cart or it can be a whole classroom
whatever the community has the re
resources to offer it's the time to
play hey we're from group seven uh we
wanted to introduce to you truck atics
um how many of you have used
yel how many of you have ever eaten out
a food
truck how many you had a great
experience at the food truck how many
had an a experience at a food truck okay
food truck Google hits in the last five
years have exploded from 8,300 to 28
million in the past five years this
shows how much the food truck industry
has been disrupted in just the past few
years we want to do this in the mobile
education truck space in order to
disrupt the education mobile truck space
for people running these trucks they
need to know the best teaching practices
they need to know best building and
material tips and what's needed out
there and for people using and learning
from these educational mobile trucks
they need to know what will you learn
what's the value of learning this way
and what are reliable reviews of the
best trucks out there like a Yelp for Ed
mobile truck trucks trackalytics
accomplishes all of this if you guys
have iPhones or laptops out you guys can
type in
www.rtic.com if you want to check it out
for
yourself um and we are going to model
how two middle schoolers I'm put on my
middle school C have might potentially
use a website like trtic
okay oh man font tropolis science truck
today in Miss frizzle's class was so
legit that rocket flying by my face was
amazing we should totally go review it
online oh what's that website again
chocal litics a all
right arrow over we have
trackalytics and wow I think there's
even a
link to Facebook and Twitter so I could
tweet out how awesome F tropis
was all
right
thanks uh and uh for our Q&A we have um
the owner of font tropolis science truck
who uses truck allytics to answer
question questions for
you other than one Vision engineering
which presented here earlier how many
mobile trucks are there Ed mobile Ed
trucks are there first of all Lots
second of all not enough third of all we
want to empower them to share their
ideas so they'll be more and we want to
make them more effective faster through
collaboration they're competing in some
Metropol areas but the one in Boston's
not directly competing with the one in
Houston they could share ideas the one
in Boston could sell stuff to the one in
Houston so that's an additional Fund
Raising source for them how are they
competing do they well if they have the
same student Market the school's not
going to have five trucks day after day
school pay them not even this works oh
this happens today yeah they pay the
trucks not necess trucks any mobile
education we we've actually met a lot of
people who do mobile education come to
the school even for Teacher um PD um
that could be a mobile ad truck but okay
so so are you considering any add
service as a truck well any service that
that a school would uh there there are
uh many diverse programs right now that
sort of take these really Dynamic
interactive um inquiry based experiences
and bring them to the school so it could
be um I'm thinking of the something
through Harvard or through MIT where
they're taking these learning
experiences and mobile bringing them to
the school site um and we uh heard some
ideas being pitched already today for
other more creative educational mobile
trucks to bring in so we're sort of
anticipating a market for Ed mobile
trucks but um as you know this is very
emergent very new trying to share best
practices so as we anticipate a pro
proliferation of these trucks that
they're able to share practices how will
the students know to go to truck
allytics to review it uh absolutely so
um as as a truck owner I would want them
to on my truck I'd have a sticker go
review me on truck alytic so more
schools get me we also have to have uh
hope to have a technology component um
to to put into trucks that would one
help track where they are so hopefully
to facilitate posting to our site and
their performance we want to empower
these innovators to grow and learn and
become better faster through this data
Big Data analysis of what's going on and
the reviews and feed
great are we starting right now and team
eight thank
you all right so courses are
traditionally designed only by teachers
but classes impact both students and
their future employers so what's the
solution the co-creation of courses that
cater to the needs of all three groups
welcome to sild an online tool that
allows students and teachers to build
curriculum together uh that focuses on
employer desired skills here's the
landing page where students and teachers
can both
enter so you can click if you're a
student or if you're a teacher and uh
here you see that a teacher can begin to
load in their course content the title
The some of the generic information um a
course description objectives and then
we've included these comment areas where
we would develop specific questions to
draw out student interests what they
hope to learn their skill sets resources
and ideas as well as critical thinking
about questions they have about the
syllabus so this would allow students to
have a voice in their curriculum as
opposed to just accepting what is
offered so this involvement student
involvement in the process will generate
buyin and ownership of the course before
it's even
begun okay and students learn a lot of
marketable skills in their courses from
communication skills learning to deal
with
ambiguity um uh teamwork skills those
are very important but oftentimes these
are not explicitly woven into the course
so the system that we've set up helps
teachers weave marketable able skills
into the courses that they're already
teaching and helps teachers think
strategically about the marketing skill
sets within their courses more exciting
students will actually have an
opportunity to connect with employers um
because at the end of of the project
they'll do a write up um and this write
up can include hashtags of those
marketable skills um which employers can
then search on um and write comments and
reviews we feel like um the real power
is in the intersection of these
viewpoints um and what we can do by all
working
together I have a question uh did you
consider any qu any things about
copyrights because once they produce uh
new elements eventually they can be
copyrighted even by students and so on
as a proposals so we thought about
making we thought about something kind
of modeled on GitHub where sort the code
is open source so the projects and the
lesson plans that you have are open
source but you can also choose to make
them private so we'd hope that in
general people would want to make them
public so that other teachers can take
the idea and expand off of them and we
could build on the foundation of
Creative Commons if we so chose I mean
people could make more open- Source
syllabi that can be shared and can be
flexible so thank you What's the timing
for a student to engage the the
co-building so if if um in an Ideal
World if the class is starting in the
fall and students have already signed up
for classes now they'd get an email
inviting them in but it could happen any
time up until the first week or so of
the class is the focus High School it uh
we began the conversation with college
but we also realized we we expanded it
so it would be a parallel process for
high school as well and part of it would
be um also cross
institution sharing resources ideas so
um is there a way that you can get a
promise of teachers and once they've
crowdsourced these ideas that they
actually use some of them is there a
benchmark for a teacher to know that she
or he did a good enough job at taking
the student feedback well we're we
actually really are ready to do this
this fall so I'm on board with my course
Museum studies at mcla in North Adams
very good and partnering with brown and
also
MIT any more
questions all right thank
you all right put your hands together
for team nine thank
you hello everyone we are team nine the
kinetic catalysts and uh I'm wondering
teachers and parents in the room have
you ever noticed this phenomenon where
sixth graders come into the school year
all brigh eyed eager to learn seventh
graders starting to get a little bit
less interested and eighth graders are
just like totally checked out to school
too cool for school that's the problem
that we want to address um we've got
three different kinds of Learners who
are feeling disconnected for three
different reasons um one kind of learner
just doesn't understand what school has
to do with their everyday
life another might be feeling um too
advanced and like they've got passion
interests that just aren't being
explored and a Third Kind might be
feeling like they've gotten the message
that they're just not good students
they're not successful and so why should
they
care and so what we uh the broad Strokes
of what we want to do is to um
re-energize Middle School using design
thinking and Project based learning so
we've developed a program called
Catalyst and the three main components
of it are teacher development sequence
learning and then a system of supports
so um this whole program would be kicked
off with um something called a design
Aon we're viewing the program sort of as
a One-Stop shop for teachers who want to
do Project based learning um so the
designathon would be where teachers and
designers would get together to develop
project ideas and we've developed a
sequence of what this program would look
like from 6th through 8th grade and so
you'll see there's a designathon during
the summer before each year and students
move gradually towards becoming um more
autonomous and self-guided in their
Project based learning and we also
developed a system of
um documentation and reflection that
happens on an ongoing basis and that's
used as assessment and also um can be
accessed by other Learners and educators
so um the supports that our teachers
would get include um hopefully
Innovation Labs within their schools
online learning communities where they
can share what's working and what's not
starter kids to get them going on these
Project based modules and finally an
expo celebration where everyone can
share the work they've
done all right team 10 thank you so much
great can I get team sorry this is team
nine can I get team 10 so how good
what's the dissemination plan for
getting this out into the wild it's a
great question so um I currently work in
the Bronx with about 44 New York City
public schools and so we would
absolutely love to start there we have a
lot of teachers who are looking for ways
to innovate their practice so teachers
would we would basically recruit
teachers to participate and they would
sign on um obviously the schools and the
administration would need to sign off on
this and we would want to develop the
system so that the we're following a
track of students and gradually building
comp capacity over the three years so
our hope is that those initial teachers
would become like ambassadors spreading
the message about this program to other
teachers within their school to other
communities as
well what what oh sorry no no what is
the the motivation of teachers to become
recruiters for this
process I think if they see the the
value the transformative power of design
thinking and Project based learning
within their own classrooms they're
going to be excited to share that
message but they complain already that
they all the time is already taken but
it only takes a few minutes to tell a
friend about a great experience in
school there's also like plenty of
teachers right now sorry about my voice
who already care a lot about trying to
implement Project based uh learning and
they just don't know where to turn to
like it's been mentioned before and so
we want to be able to generate projects
for different subjects in different age
ranges uh where people can know okay
there's been a symposium with really
smart people trying to figure out the
best answer to this problem we can just
go uh to there and see what they
Solutions were and that's how we can
really get the word out about this to
the
world are they just building curriculum
during that time or are they also doing
it themselves or building their own
skills yeah it's actually both so
they're they're developing actual
curriculum to implement and then they're
also gaining skills for design based um
design design based approaches to
learning um so they're getting more
comfortable with it they're getting to
experience it firstand themselves not un
like the design
shop thank you
let's move it over
for let's give it up for team
10 hello we are boxed in boxed out also
known as bio Mary and Mark Marley and
Anna and our idea is looking at the
question how can we design student
education that matches the learning
style of every student we found that the
Gap right now is that in traditional
classrooms their projects and
curriculums are designed to deliver
uniform experiences to a diverse group
of students so how are we going to fix
this you know bio gave us this uh
database of information and I think they
have something on the theme of energy
and our students can choose whichever
thing they want hey Mark you want
something sure let's see there you go
take a look I'm going to do this one
Farm to Table is the question is how
much energy is needed to produce a weak
of food in different countries so this
is just an example of one of the
projects that we can use um we hope to
create a database where ultimately
students and teachers can find a variety
of projects and resources and then also
extend this so that students can form
communities online to Showcase projects
with their peers around the world so
what do we need to do first of all this
is a very ambitious project so we're
going to roll us out in sort of multiple
phases the first is just over the summer
to sort of build Outreach talk to the
teachers build a spreadsheet of projects
that already exist because there are
resources out there in different topic
areas and there are also resources that
are just Project based but we want to
tie this so it goes with the curriculum
with the standards we also want to
identify pilot participants and sort of
build our team and expertise so in the
upcoming school year in fall and spring
we want to have an initial pilot sort of
build our technical database and
everything that we really want to
include as far as the budget goes I mean
this is something that takes a lot of
money and time the biggest thing
actually will be in the technical
impementation and the roll out um but
there's also meetings and such so we
just want to thank everyone at Design
shop and we are welcome to help your
questions
now
so if there are as many students and
types of learning styles how are you
going to match student learning sty to
the number of kinds of activities there
are are there going to be
recommendations for teachers are there
going to be ways of helping them assess
their Student Styles other than
self-report I mean what have you got in
mind for that well I think a lot of
those things exist and some of the
products that were brought forth are
doing that um we want to bring forth uh
open-ended things like Makey Makey and
Legos that the students can use for many
you know reasons that but we want to
create the database and then um narrow
it down by theme and give the student
the opportunity to choose what appeals
to them in terms of a process maybe it's
pretext maybe it's some other type of
Project based opportunity so it's really
putting the control in the students
hands and if they decided not to use
this
opportunity they have to choose well
this is actually a model that can
actually depend on what this teacher is
also doing as well so we don't really
want to push students into silos into
buckets into tracks They actually move
from one thing to another maybe they
want to learn about the physics of
musical instruments but in another time
they would rather just sort of have a
traditional lecture style book or maybe
they would rather watch a video for
another topic my question is if they
keep on giving up one after the other oh
I don't really want that give me another
one and another one and at the end they
actually didn't fully experiment
anything well they can also tweak the
projects that are there that the teacher
proposes or they can come up with their
own project and talk to the teacher and
work with the teacher more as a mentor
or facilitator and and then and then the
teacher can put that project up on the
project database if it was successful
and then other teachers can use it
learning is about experimentation and I
hear kids are not trly creative so each
student their
own each student their own own separate
or if they want to work in a group they
can they have that
option let's give a round of applause
for team
11 hi I'm Roxy archal I'm from Team 11
and this is Gabriel we are just a team
of
two and uh what we worked on for uh the
past 48 Hours was developing something
called Test Plus and uh what we
found we've had major technical
difficulties
so okay well no okay well one of the
major problems I mean as you've seen
this is just fantastic all of the ideas
that have been thrown out but um in
order to really make these ideas
possible and happen in the classroom uh
We've realized that one of the major
problems is that it's not that standards
aren't aligned to real life 21st century
skills like Innovation uh creativity
collaboration because the common Corp
actually does encompass these it's just
that they're not assessed on
standardized tests so this is currently
how we are assessing and as you can see
there's no collaboration taking place
here there's no Innovative thinking at
all so in comes uh our plan are we using
assessment to build the next generation
of citizens
no um how can we assess those skills so
the idea behind Test Plus is that it
adds practical observation into the
standardized testing model through
technology uh and our plan is to
leverage current technology being
developed at the world's top
universities like MIT Harvard
Stanford uh with their for example here
a signature track which uh is allows for
distance certification virtual iding and
cloud mentorship and integrated into the
K12
environment what does what what what can
it do it makes way for innovation in the
classroom to be widespread it expands
assessment time it assesses 21st century
skills in a better way it captures
skills that aren't being captured
already it's Progressive testing and
it's awesome thank you
you just slide to the left I should play
that song every
time awesome
te yes what it is yeah so essentially
what it is would be an alternative form
of assessing some of the 21st century
skills using the online technology that
has already been developed by some of
the major universities what does it do
well basically we would Lobby to
integrate uh technology into the
classroom so that it can are you doing
are you using video are you using you
collaborative skills and different 21st
century skills that aren't being tested
on okay so if they how would they be
evaluated who would be doing the
evaluation um members from the industry
uh just general members from the
industry would be uh tasked to to do
this collaboratively they would be uh um
trained for 6 months to to to be able to
certify testers so that they can uh uh
successfully uh
uh assess uh using this technology
remotely yeah ours was mostly conceptual
like based rather than like here's a
product that can actually go through is
just the idea of there are already so
many products out there but Innovation
within the classroom is not the norm
across the United States it has happens
in very specific districts usually
wealthy ones because within other
schools the focus is on okay here are
the standards that are being tested when
my student is sitting here I need to
focus on that collaboration is not
assessed I don't have room to focus on
those skills while actually those are
the most important skills to really pave
the way for the future generation
working in Industry so it helps so if we
so if we integrate it and it and it
counts for the the the standardized test
maybe 5% or 2% for the first 3 to 5
years then you can uh push for more
teachers to be teaching 21 it holds just
as much weight as the standards that are
assessed on the mcast or the park
therefore it will be taken care of on in
the everyday setting in the classroom
just as well
so 3.0 a represent and solve problems
involving involving
multiplication right testate excuse me
don't hat in my classroom will you
please take that hat off thank you all
right everybody what are you looking at
no no okay three * four do it do it
right now right now you don't know it
don't
you
seen
Ethan will you tell me what the number
three stands for in this equation it's
like the amount of something in equation
will you agree class do you agree sure
great uh tinina will you please tell me
what the number four stands in this
equation how many times the number of
times that we need
to do it add the threes great class do
you agree yes you agree Ethan will you
please stand up he's a third grader so
he's stand Ethan we he's standing up
fail teacher fail that's okay it's it's
human nature to fail that's okay so
check it out Ethan you have the three
things right that you're going to do
will you please come up with a set of
three movements one two three nice Ethan
you have to you have to use those three
movements and how many times are you
going to repeat them four times will you
please show me that one two three four 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 3 * 4 is is 12 class I
can't hear
you all right so the problem that we've
identified is that standardized
education produces students that are not
engaged our solution is oh our solution
is we're going to make fun Project based
learning how are we going to do that
we're going to use dance and all the
Arts going do it all together what are
we going to do after that we're going to
collect the data after we collect the
data we're going to show it to policy
Changers we're going to tell them you
need to do this after we do that they're
going to like us on Facebook give us
money and arts integration will happen
everybody will have
fun thank you so much team 12 awesome
and they live uh happy ever happily ever
after happily ever after by the way we
should say that we're not really only
testing for grades we're testing for
we're U not only collecting data for
grades we're collecting data for
engagement we want students to feel
engaged with engag question oh
yeah so do you think administrators are
going to have fun also with the fund
think who the administrators are they
going to have fun why I think so um I
think they're going to have fun first of
all because they're going to see the
whole community of the class room
changing and the students having fun
with it and they're going to be like
whoa you know this actually works our
students are engaged our students are
doing fun things and they want to be
here whereas before they really didn't
want to be here so fun is going to come
from the students from the ground up
into the whole school community and can
you control the fun yes well because
it's a structured chaos well you control
it because these are not just activities
that we're like doing to play games
these are we're design we're designing
the activities all student centered and
all connected to the Common Court um and
and based on student interest so it's
fun learning but it's also guided
Explorations that the teacher is doing
and if the teacher does not want to do
it well if the teacher doesn't want to
do it it's one of the things
where you you know you can't it has to
start in a way you have to start with
the
teacher it's one of those things where
if the teacher doesn't want to do it
well then this is not the right thing
for that teacher I it's one of the
things maybe one of the things where
also teachers you identify a teacher
that would be willing to Pro um to
prototype this in their classroom and as
the buzz of those students being
successful and engaged the word spreads
and it grows out within your community
thank
you it's just it's a activity within the
day like they they use it you imagine
it's five minutes a day from each every
one of their teachers or how what does
it look like it can it can grow in any
direction from 5 minutes all the way
through the whole day experiential
learning Collaborative Learning all
different kinds of
learning all right so put your hands
together for Team
13 great all right thank you leadership
for tomorrow depends on how we educate
our students today especially in science
technology engineering and math
President Obama September
2010 stem based job jobs are expected to
grow two times as fast as any other jobs
1 million additional STEM related grads
are needed over the next 10 years but
the pipeline is small and we're not
capturing a large enough group to meet
that
need by broadening the
pipeline by engaging engaging students
in stem early we can make it by making
it Fun by making it interesting and
appealing to a larger group we can
connect them and increase and capture
more people in the pipeline more
students in the pipeline line our idea
Connect middle school students with
ingenium our shipping container filled
with tools supplies all the stuff that
you might just find around and this is
designed in such a way that it allows
students to design develop prototype
solutions to the challenges that they
want to tackle making stem relevant
interesting and expanding the number of
students in the
pipeline how does it work the students
identify or the community members
identify local issues we work to curate
those projects and the and through the
curation process the um the students and
the teachers work to select what those
projects might be and then the container
is dropped off uh once that particular
community that once that particular
school is
selected the unique features of this is
that we're targeting middle middle
school students and again these are the
middle school students that are um able
to uh to would be interested in tackling
the project low cost shipping container
is about approximately $3,000 the stuff
inside very low Tech Comm it involves
the community it's scalable and um in
terms of timing uh we can load up and
roll us out in about a
month great thank you come on
over all right team 14 where you at
custom container based projects
aren't custom they AR custom I'm go
ahead
um so the containers are meant to be
filled with just our with with stuff
that we aren't afraid to be uh not
afraid to be broken so they're not
they're very low Tech plastic bottles
wires um anything that you might find
around so again we're trying to keep the
cost down uh very low Tech things that
that that we're not afraid of of
students breaking and um and as I said
the shipping containers are about 3,00
who would buy this and how would they
find out about it who would make the who
would buy this and how would they find
out about it so that's part of our
funding uh model so we've talked about
many things whether it be um you know uh
uh recruiting corporate sponsorship and
um uh you know proaps uh connecting into
organizations like you know the National
Science Foundation and others um and I
don't know do you guys want to add would
teachers be able to use these the stuff
in the
container yes I mean how how are they
prepared are they do they yeah so our
hope is actually to get maybe graduate
students studying design to help
facilitate these container so they know
the design process so they come in
they're the ones who do all the sort of
curriculum planning up front they know
how to run the process so for the
teachers they're not paying for the
materials they're not doing any
curriculum planning we're trying to make
it easy for them so you know the
students or someone in the community
submits these ideas we curate them say
this is a great problem we want to
figure out you know how do we use this
empty lot in the community we come in
and we work with the students to to sort
of help them develop solutions for that
is it a rental model like the container
comes for a certain amount of time or is
it a permanent model yeah so we're
trying to figure out what the right time
frame is and and Steve suggested three
weeks is probably a good time frame and
I I think it's something you'd probably
prototype and try to figure out you know
because a one question is how long do we
have the students for on a day-to-day
basis are they there for the whole day
or just a couple of hours so I think
it's something we' prototype and I think
that the idea was that we were imagining
it uh leaving it there for 3 to four
weeks to allow time for the Stu for the
uh the students in the the school to
feel ownership and then move it off to
the
next and put your hands together for
team
14 all right summer school sucks let's
be honest so I'm a kid I failed my math
class I'm going to go in for a couple
couple of months and do the same
lectures I just did in the same uh sty
old classroom I just sat in all year
this is we can do better than that so
let's enter the lens classroom and so
this is a classroom that is designed to
enable individualized curriculum through
the lens of educational gaming so let's
talk about this for a second I want you
to close your eyes and I want you to
think think step one Chuck all the
chairs out the window burn the desks
let's clear out the physical space step
two let's put in some new stuff but keep
it more open let's put in some
whiteboards let's put in some TV
consoles and some gaming consoles and
let's start to think about what this
looks like let's take an example of a
math class the kids are all working on
their own topics some are doing common
denominators some are multiplying
fractions and
we are all working on different things
and the your your teacher is getting
constant formative assessment data from
the input of the game and they're
walking around with this tablet and
instead of being behind the desk they
are walking up to individual students
who they're seeing Oh man common
denominators isn't going so hot for
Jimmy so you go over and you do what you
want to do as a teacher one-on-one
tutorial work and the students are
engaged in their excited because this is
nothing like the classroom that they're
used to it's loud it's exciting it's
interactive it's great and so this is
not just for math we use this as a
really great example but we hope to be
able to grow beyond that into other
subjects and into other phases of active
learning that this type of classroom
environment would
enable so
describe a sort of Utopia but how do you
get
there so I guess the main point is how
to combine experience of have a a clean
environment in the class with a gaming
so a platform look at with that in which
you can provide really real task to the
students and using math to accomplish
something really real so how we can make
the experience of the summer be
something different they already had in
the previous year so that's the the
combination the experience plus the
content and I think we saw summer school
as this opportunity to try something new
try something flexible try using within
the space of the classrooms that they
exist but removing what's there and
trying to reimagine what that space can
be so it's like summer school in an
arcade in a way yes right
yeah and how do we Infuse what's in
these games we love games right so
what's in these games and how can we
Infuse academic content in those games
and that's kind of where we need to go
next is developing games that has the
kind of academic language academic
literacy and academic content that um
you know that will that kids will be
exposed to through what they're already
being engaged and motivated to do at
home so now you know they're doing it in
newp is there a mechanism to stay out of
the Fringe and enter the center and take
on because you know we can create a
million alternative programs so here you
have this idea you're going to test in
the the summer school pretty safe for
districts how how do you push against
the center how do you go it me to be
there or is it intentionally there like
this is specifically to help bring
people I think if I think if a model
Works people are going to be excited by
it and if you're using gaming if you get
if you access that private gaming um
developing world that has a ton of money
schools and administrators are probably
going to be pretty pretty excited
parents are they going to be excited to
send the kids to do video games if the
kids like it and the kids are learning
well and the kids are doing better on
test I think the parents are going to
like it too okay
let's put our hands together for
te15 all right so if I could have you
guys all look under your chairs tell me
if you have a purple Post-It
note I think you're going to find that
most of you do not only about 30% of you
have a Post-It note the reason for that
is because 30% is about the number the
percentage of students that are engaged
in classrooms today and it's also the
percentage of teachers that find
meaningful time to do collaboration now
me I was a product of No Child Left
Behind I was asked to memorize
information I was asked to take multiple
choice tests and now that I'm a first
year teacher I rely on that how I was
taught to inform my students and so I
ask what resources do I have in order to
make my curriculum when I'm expected to
do common core and make it more engaging
I have two basically one my textbook
which is still nclb structured which
still has multiple choice which is still
not very real world applied and I have
my fellow teachers who've also been
teaching NB for many years and we don't
have enough time to collaborate so what
options do I have all right so for
teachers like will we invented open box
so open box is a is a platform that
involves communities of teachers of
students of parents administrators
college students and businesses they
they brainstorm real life real world
relevant challenges that teachers and
students can then go into the classroom
and solve so here's how how it works
will can go online make a profile um
specify some things about his class like
the grade the subject the concept he
orders a kit you have a delivery he gets
delivery so he can either choose a lucky
choose a choose one for us to surprise
him with and so if he does on the big
day he opens it with his class and taada
it's a surprise it's a real world
relevant challenge for will for his
students to solve and
so um open box is there are no right or
wrong answers it's about fun it's about
engagement it's about learning and so at
the end students are tasked with the um
toas to retach this to their teachers
and then they go back with feedback with
advice and this collaboration is
key all
right who's going to pay for all of this
who's going to pay for all of this this
is like a think about as a red box or a
Netflix subscription you get the box uh
you've already paid for it when you
return it you actually get some money
refunded back or if you return the
results of the project you get it back
so this is a for-profit funded model by
the consumer and so those don't have the
ability to do it communities which
challenges they're not inside this
project bring Foundation support
absolutely
Y and what was that last piece you said
really fast about students teaching it
back to their teachers so it's more of a
reflective model as well so if you if
the students have the Mastery of
whatever it is that they've learned and
they can teach it back to the instructor
that is the highest level if you will of
teaching and that's what we're hoping
now we're kind of like challenging that
and now bringing back the students teach
us the teachers an example of one of the
challenges sort of like a birch box like
all these other consumer box in the Box
what was um there was a problem in the
Box basically I was telling them about a
time I traveled to Rwanda there's a big
problem with like maintaining water and
like not having to travel far so there's
a problem statement in there that says
you know here's some some materials
construct something that is able to make
the water transportable that you can
travel with it that you can easily you
know access it so that you don't have to
be you know traveling twice a week with
your class to get water or you know Etc
so we just put whatever was in the what
was accessible to us in the design shop
so obviously we would maybe pre
pre-think a little more what we would
give the students um but you know we
sort of leave it up to them to be
creative and and see what they come up
with there's no real right or wrong
answer but the beauty is that it mats
back to standards you can actually use
in the real world so this real model
that you can use comes to you in a box
and the teacher is on the same side as
the students because we're all trying to
problem solve together it democratizes
the classroom right and more importantly
I think this collabor this notion of
collaboration so will is one I think
everybody in this room is one and wants
to build so we want to harvest that and
you know build it organically from the
bottom up you know to make sure that if
you make a mistake how do you correct it
if you have the wrong box content to
this person how do you correct this I
mean really being flexible like that's
something that you need that's a skill
you need to have in the the real
business World um kind of using what you
have be creative make
Solutions we'll send you another
one all right so put your hands together
for team
16 hi I'm Ted and uh this is Kelsey and
we are the Hands-On team projects team
uh also known as hot
projects okay so our problem was very
basic we have a lot of all over the
world um communities that don't have
resources and who lack Hands-On
education and learning opportunities and
also in these communities in every
Community you're always going to find
problems that affect yourself or quality
of life um so we wanted to see what
these what would happen if students
tried to solve these
problems so our goal is to empower young
people in in developing countries and
low resource communities to recognize
problems in their community and actually
um address them tackle them uh headon
um and uh we're going to be providing a
valuable learning experience that they
can't get from a traditional classroom
setting okay so we have a little bit of
storyboard for you so first the the
students are identifying a problem in
their community so this case they need
to cross a stream in order to go home
all right so we're going to pair them
with a uh trained facilitator um as well
as a uh they're going to have access to
a dedicated space equipped with an
Internet connected computer uh and a
basic maker space with con construction
tools
materials and then they're going to do
background research on their problem and
in their
Community um we're giving them uh a a
web platform so they can uh look online
see what uh other teams have done in the
past uh document their project as
they're going along and um and share
their projects get feedback from other
students elsewhere and be connected with
resources um and then they're going to
use what they've learned through their
internet research and by applying the
education that they've had so far to
solve this problem so in this case
they're trying to build a foot bridge
over the river sometimes they'll fail
they'll learn to deal with failure to
learn from their mistakes and also
they're using resources found in their
community and the students will
eventually find an effective solution
after trial and error um and then
students can uh help uh later students
to to find projects to identify
challenges and we work with other
organizations to do this thank
you
how do you surpass the trial and error
continuation how do you actually
incentivate to keep on trying uh so uh
from the beginning we want the students
choosing projects that they're
passionate about so we want to go
through um a a process not just a
brainstorming coming up with something
and starting to work on it um but
actually convincingly um enthusiastic
and interested in solving the problem so
for for example um uh if if they're
fixing uh open GS or there's a stream in
front of their um house they need across
or if there's fly infestation or if it's
um there's not enough lighting these are
going to be problems that um are are
important to to them to people in their
Community but but who supervised that so
so the facilitator um is going to uh
we're thinking to recruit uh recent
College grads um they can do it as a um
a service with a small stien kind of
like Teach for America or teach for
India so
P so so we're we're talking about having
a a nonprofit um organization so we
would uh require require funding um but
we're working with um minimal
infrastructure and we're not hiring a
professional we're hiring someone just
out of college um in India where we're
planning to to Pilot this um there is no
lack of recent College grads who um are
looking for
jobs
questions I guess how do you get beyond
the trial and error
method they have incentive to want to do
better because it affects their
Community but it's not just trial and
eror they're um they have access to to
um vast online resources and people to
guide them and accessing those resources
to previous projects but you know to to
Wikipedia um to Google uh so it's not
it's not just trial and error um uh they
wouldn't uh they would actually um
benefit from uh everyone else's
experience um from Instructables for
example and in any great learning
experience in any great process when
you're doing experiment you're going to
fail and you're going to learn from it
so
good great thank
you um okay well one of the issues we
have today in the education system is we
don't have enough time to try and to
fail failure is rendered invisible and
we're only allowed to see the success at
the end you try again you can fail again
and you can fail better fail forward and
fail early and often there's a tradition
of failure experimentation and document
ment ation we need to continue to
nurture lifelong Learners and to D
destigmatize failure failure and success
so we came up with the fail proof epic
fail
Journal which is um a kind of
documentation tool for students to um
kind of learn from their mistakes and
our kind of mission statement with this
is to encourage documentation of
experiences in a way that will help
utilize visualize and understand
successes and failures so that you can
understand them and help you be more
productive in the future yeah so we we
don't want we want them to take agency
and engage in the world and we don't
want them to do this without fail like
uh so we want to be more than a journal
more than a lab notebook but less than
like just a fixed lessons because we
want them to uncover these themselves uh
so we want to make something that uh
they can that that they find they find
the way things break uh epic fails give
info that gives vital info to the next
stage so we want this to stay analog uh
it's important that uh you take this
places you wouldn't bring your computer
or your power book it's like you want to
take this into the the field and be like
recording things as you go um so like in
some ways we want to maybe make it
weatherproof but other ways like maybe
it'd be good if it could like you could
also compost it or something you know
like and it might like grow like kind of
take your failures and make them grow up
to the next stage um but so changing
that F to P we can progress prototype a
lot of things um and the learning is the
whole process um so to actually make
this happen we can um create a team to
put the content in the journal um
notebook and the best part of it is this
that it's easy everyone can use it it's
also
um we're think pre-int preprinted
templates or grids like there might be
stencils or stickers depending on the
age group but like they might be prompts
and visual examples about how other
people do this process and we can engage
with people in the community to show how
they
feel thank you so much you guys sco on
over to your
judges I just realized the judges it
feels like a design critique so it's
like so perfect the way it's set up um
so was going to put the seed money for
for a thing like this we're the compost
for the seed
bunny you guys a little more the camera
sorry but the Partnerships we were
thinking would be schools um any schools
so that every um student has an access
to it and again sponsored by a community
organization or something to like
develop it but we're hoping to be able
to give boxes of them to like a class to
test it in a classroom or something like
that and the idea is I was just going to
say the idea that we didn't get to
mention in our presentation is that um
it's going to be used in the realm
that's in between school and the
extracurricular activities because in
school you have the structure of the
classroom and the teacher to support you
at the YMCA or the Boys and Girls Club
you have that structure to support you
but in the activities in between on the
bus rides when you're at the park things
like that when you're doing your um
Hobbies this is where you kind of um
make the the connections between what
you're learning about in the classroom
and how it it's applied in the real
world and so this is kind of
that's definitely the hope and we can
see how it's used and there's a thing
where you can like maybe you you make a
prototype and it can fail but can you
take a failure and make a prototype next
like can that go both ways so maybe if
maybe if it works in classrooms teachers
can use that to like have an alternate
route past F to turn your F into a on
pap going to rely on already developed
literacy skills um well that's another
thing that we're thinking about is that
it can help with that because by
documenting you can practice your
writing your ability to communicate
visually your drawing
I think there's drawing like drawing
Maps like making playlists kind of like
play testing your own like Cycles so
then you can see if it has replay value
like was that mistake like is it make
fertile information like in doing those
things like it's not necessarily a
written Journal it's a journal of just
communicating visually so whatever that
may be yeah but you might do fiction
experiments or something to like come up
with I
mean we're thinking two different sides
that either it it has kind of like
something that you can compare and maybe
sh share online that does use a fixed
template but also always open space to
like id8 as well so
but administrators and others to buy
into this just give the students first
and start from the bottom up have the
kids bring them in M thank
you let's give a round of applause to
team
18 great wonderful uh well first of all
thank you uh we want to introduce all of
you to our friend Alex Alex is a person
and a thing and uh one of the questions
we wanted to answer was how can we
advise Alex so that he or she is aware
of his or her life choices and and part
of us introducing you to Alex is
explaining a little bit about who Alex
is Alex is is lowincome minority student
uh he's in the 10 he or she is in the
10th grade and and and they're a good
student but most most importantly he or
she is not aware of the vast array of
resources available to them so Alex is
confused you know he or she is
interested in a lot of different topics
but doesn't really know where to go the
counselor at the school is a little bit
overtaxed there's 1,200 students in the
high school and doesn't really have time
to sit down and do career counseling
with them the teacher overwhelmed
because there's 30 kids in the classroom
and they have to try to you know also
grade and and spend a lot of time doing
things related to the curriculum but
Alex wants to explore his or her life
opportunities so uh we wanted Alex to
meet Alex and Alex is an Innovative
online lowcost platform that connects uh
students that don't know what choices
they have to professionals uh in the
community uh peers researchers uh
professors who who can talk to them a
little bit more about what opportunities
are available to them uh so it's really
important for them to connect with these
people so
Alex uh creates an online
profile and can interact with all of
these different uh stakeholders who are
interested in Alex you know knowing what
kind of choices he or she has as far as
career or college opportunities and we
want to emphasize the the college and
career Readiness because College may be
for some students maybe not for others
so well you already have a website in
Portuguese i s saw it
was how was it low cost how was it low
well because we're going to be uh once
we launch it uh you know we're hoping to
sustain uh the platform mainly
online um because we know that you know
for some students it's hard for them to
physically get two people so if you're
in a neighborhood maybe your family
doesn't have a car you're able to go
online at any point maybe live chat with
your your online Mentor uh get advice
from them uh video chat with them or
talk with them on the phone um and we
would like to be able to set up
opportunities for there to be that human
to human interaction as well but in the
case that students aren't able to do
that you know they're able to to
hopefully you know get an internet
connection either at school or at home
that allows them to interact with uh the
people that can expose them to some of
their life options you guys connected
with career Village or path Source or
any of the other Solutions of this sort
that are out there uh we have not but we
think that this would be a great
addition to the menu of options that are
out there and possibly lend support and
maybe Target specific uh you know groups
of students that we feel need the
additional support and additional
resources and is there is there a way to
sort of help scale it you know beyond
like one to one or yeah well
Al Alex is the every man so Alex isn't
just one student we we would hope to
start at a school actually uh and see
you know maybe over a a two-year period
or so that's why we started with the
10th grade and to see over two years or
so you know is this something that's
actually scalable and and possibly
expand it to other schools that that
have a similar interest in seeing
students connect with professionals but
who maybe don't have those in school
resources to do
that and without further Ado team 19 yep
now also known as team 19 project is
called full ahead and we welcome you to
join us on our journey our problem how
can we create greater access to steam
opportunities we are passionate about
reframing stem to
St to steam an authentic and integrated
way of approaching these disciplines
into our curriculum we've thought about
access in two key ways access to
resources for communities and students
and access to curricular resources for
educators we created a mobile learning
lab to allow for the mobility of
resources and to integrate Building
Bridges to bring learning to the
community Through connecting classroom
experiences with real life experiences
in this way students become researchers
and experts for example in a unit about
plants students could collect data about
growing paint pots to hold their plant
and represent this data graphically to
share with a larger
audience Educators often struggle with
embedding integrating steem activities
into typical routines because they
haven't learned that way themselves and
they don't have time to develop the idea
because teachers would learn alongside
students in this mobile lab they would
experience learning a concept in an
integrative way to conquer the issue of
developing ideas part of our
professional development would be to
create time for a participant adult to
create new steam experiences that would
then be helded in our Cloud repository
all resources will be available to all
participants and to incentivize use of
the cloud through uploading and
downloading new units and project will
use badging and discount for the bus so
what does this look like in
implementation a startup cost
approximately $20,000 with 5,000
budgeted to the purchase of a used bus
10,000 to Staffing 5,000 to outfitting
this bus we would fund raise from local
businesses and philanthropy our ongoing
overhead should cover Staffing
maintenance and turnover of bus content
some up overhead can be covered through
fees to bring it back to your community
as welled continued fundraising and
Grant
we would start by bringing full steam
ahead to Phoenix Arizona and then scale
through key points in Arizona and
hopefully across multiple States from
there all
right thank you so much
questions why
Arizona actually that was sort of a
random selection we found a website that
ranks some of the most um depressed uh
districts in the country and I just
scanned it really quickly and there was
lot aona so why is the bus essential to
this model
Mobility we really focused on trying to
um meet people wherever they were so
bring the resources in case they don't
have a space in their um school or if
their spaces are rigid this would allow
a little bit of flexibility so what
happens when the bus leaves hopefully
the teachers have been so inspired by
the process that they're uploading
materials to the online repository so
that they'll continue to teach in that
way
I think another key idea about the bus
that I wanted to share that we thought
is having the bus actually be part of
this steam experience so we were
thinking if we could get a we could buy
a bus or donate a bus we could then work
with the local Community College to help
us convert this bus so that it can be
run on vegetable oil or on diesel or
something like that if a bus needs
maintenance then we could bring it to
maybe a vocational technical college and
they could work on the maintenance for
it so the bus itself is both bringing
access literally but also serving a a
vehicle for the lar it's a steam the bus
itself is a steam project how would you
select where to go
first no no no not Arizona but you have
a lot of schools in Arizona wanted to
have it there so what how you select
which would be the right crowd in which
school I think the easiest thing to do
so one of the things that I really like
about the bus is that it offers the
opportunity to do sort of like cross
networking so you could start like let's
say with a project um at elementary
school then take the bus to the middle
school then to high school so I would
actually focus on a a school school that
has really good vertical alignment so
you could start showing people how this
bus could build community both um within
a district but also within teachers that
make
sense what about the free time of the
bus nobody's using it what do you want
to do everybody's going to want to be
using it all the time okay good over
taxed
let's keep the Applause going for team
20 ready yes the problem I'm a student
and I'm tested all the time um
oftentimes in a similar fashion multiple
choice some writing testing is boring
but my teachers feel compelled to mimic
summative accountability methods off
with my
head help
okay assessment is a necessary evil to
hold teachers accountable for their
students learning but the problem like
Andre put is that students are over
tested and multiple choice tests they're
not fun they're not motivating and they
just don't really look like anything you
see in the real world the solution to
this problem would be to have more
creative forms of Assessments
assessments that are fun that are
motivating that mimic situations you see
in real life so things like interviews
oral presentations writing prompts the
problem with these types of Assessments
is that grading can be subjective and
inconsistent and Grading can take a
significantly long time so our strategy
for solving this problem is to take
machine Lear learning algorithms and
what machine learning algorithms do is
they take the qualitative data that you
get from these creative forms of
Assessments and they turn it into the
quantitative data that you need to fit
into the accountability metrics that you
use like grades so we would take this
technology and we would make it
accessible to teachers teach teachers
how to use use it and what this would do
it was it was it would increase the
teachers abilities to use more creative
forms of assessment in their classrooms
things like interviews oral
presentations writing prompts because it
would increase the consistency for the
grading and it would reduce the amount
of time that teachers would need to
spend grading in order to use these
types of
Assessments um but there's
more so we would start small like maybe
develop a program to grade third grade
writing prompts once we knew it worked
then we would scale up by looking into
other grades you know scale over the
entire K12 system and also develop
programs to grade other types of
Assessments like oral
transcripts all right do a little
electric slide to the left great thank
you guys the machine learning approaches
require at least a hundred um examples
in order to train the system
where would you be F what kinds of
grades or subjects would you be focused
on so we would well we would be focused
on um grades in the K K12 system so we
would start small like I said with maybe
third grade writing prompts um and the
technology is improving so there was a
system that was developed this last year
that doesn't require hundreds of writing
samples in order to produce grades it's
getting better and better but we would
start small with maybe like a writing
prompt for a third grade classroom that
uses a textbook that's commonly used in
like all the third grade classrooms um
just to make sure that it
worked and what does the teacher lose
and what does the teacher gain right so
what the teacher gains is time the
ability to use more creative assessments
a little bit more flexibility in how she
or he develops his or her curriculum
what the teacher loses is a little bit
of the personal aspect she doesn't
actually he or she doesn't you know go
through the process of physically
grading every single student's um
assignment so you lose a little bit of
the feedback loop but you gain more
flexibility in terms of your curriculum
and the types of assessment you can
use and so do you imagine it going
Beyond writing can it go to assessing
projects in some way or or gu you write
about your project and that's how it
does it well so I I can Envision it um
being used to assess interviews or oral
presentations in terms of projects
because all it would require is an
additional piece of software to
transcribe that student speech into a
trans
and then have the machine learning
algorithm grade the transcript um as far
as physical projects I'm not
sure how do you measure the intangibles
in a oral transcript of body language
and engagement of right so in terms of
that there would probably be some
components of the project that the
teacher would have to grade him or
herself it wouldn't be a BL endl and we
wouldn't want it to be we would want the
student or the teacher to be somewhat
engaged in the students like project
presentation let's welcome team
21 okay we're reality to policy we are
Helen Mariel and Mary so we all know
that in every Community there could be
more um more engagement for students
with stem taking a look at my school
district shamberg district 54 outside of
Chicago Illinois we are a majority min
District all elementary kids in our
district are exposed to really rich stem
activities still we find that when kids
move on to the Junior High um lots of
girls and underrepresented minorities
aren't taking advantage of those
opportunities that they get at Junior
High as an example we have a gems
program that hosts uh 300 students so
that's girls engaged in math and science
but what we find is that less than 10%
are African-American and about 15% are
Hispanic so in districts like this there
is a door to opportunity but not all
students are going through the door and
our solution to this problem is to
create a new staff position called the
stem Community liaison and this could be
one or more people per District based on
the community needs so the stem
Community Liaisons will link the schools
uh with stem programs the stem industry
that are looking for future workers and
also the families in the community and
the eons will create um personal
onetoone relationships with the students
and parents and also provide information
and resources to parents in their native
language if that is needed so here's an
example what a liaison would do in one
week on Monday you could see the liaison
connecting with Community Partners such
as hospitals businesses and they're
connecting real world experiences
outside the classroom so you give these
children the opportunities on Tuesday
you see the liaison visiting science
classrooms and interact AC in with
students on the third day on Wednesday
you see that they're reaching out to
parents in their native language using
bilingual flyers and also making
personal phone calls so again you're
making this real relationship with the
families directly and on Thursday you
could see our liaison communicating on
the online platform and Friday you could
see them also gathered all here at this
event again with the partners liaison
the parents and the students all around
stem events thank
you thank you guys so much
uh how do you think the parents would
react to losing the direct linkage to
the teachers I don't think anybody is
suggesting that you would lose the
direct link to this to the parents and
to the teachers but I think what the
stem liaison would do is kind of another
layer of that to say you know like if we
have a large Hispanic population I'm
going to call you and I'm going to speak
to you in your native language and I'm
going to say hey we're having this great
event this week your student has an
awesome thing that they made I hope that
we'll see you there I hope you'll come
in and then again at the event they're
going to be there to welcome parents in
again in their native language so
they're feeling comfortable but
definitely the teachers going to be
there too and the teacher's always going
to be you know connecting with the um
with the family as wellison is more like
a support to the teacher and a network
between the industry and the school and
the famili but you're discriminating so
English speakers would have direct
access and speak with the teachers and
uh non- English
speakers still they would still
communicate with the English speakers
but we're saying we're supplementing I
think you could have different types of
family Liaisons you'd really need to
look at your particular school districts
so you could have um uh Liaisons that
speak different languages and English
speakers I mean the point is that you
want to have access so everyone can um
communicate and understand did you um in
terms of cost sharing for this new FTE
for districts um did you think about not
burdening the district anymore with with
another higher but cost sharing with
local Tech groups or yeah absolutely so
we're connecting back to to Industry so
I think that we would hope that um it
would be a win-win for industry to maybe
donate some money to this as well as you
know what they're doing is they're
letting the district know these are the
skills that we need workers to have 15
20 years from now so they're helping to
develop that that Workforce those skills
that people are going to need as well as
maybe giving back to the district and
looking great to their Community
wouldn't they say I'm already paying my
taxes take it out of that not
necessarily I think you know I think
corporations want to be good corporate
stewards give them all of our enthusiasm
and our Applause
22 all right uh good afternoon so we are
P2P Learning Tree and we want to improve
student achievement through greater
student ownership and
connection students are thought of as
passive instead of active Learners our
school system I know I've been sitting
in a Latin class and a teacher who I
have no connection with is almost
preaching me information and half it's
gone past
me sorry research tells us and reveals
that of all the different ways that we
can have teaching and learning in
classrooms and in school systems
discussion groups practice by doing and
teaching others the immediate use of
knowledge are the three best best ways
to improve retention and deepen learning
to do that we're going to have to
actually think about the learning
environment and the thinking that we're
doing in our
learning so what if we challenge the
assumption that teacher students have to
learn from expert teachers so now
imagine a different kind of school one
where students learn by teaching other
students so what would that look like I
mean you guys many of you are teachers
in this room and so what what what kind
of student learning would be there if
students had to stand in your shoes so
the process here imagine a head teacher
teaching say about four students and
each of them are not only taught the
content but also how to teach they go
off they prepare their lesson plan they
get feedback from their their teacher
and they go off and teach their peers
and the process continues on and how do
we manage quality in this whole system
so we're trying to build a platform
around this to provide contents um as
you can see um we're trying to provide
feedback mechanisms analytics to find
out what students know
where and our program considers all the
stakeholders because we don't
essentially change anything we still
have a certified teacher who's teaching
to all the current standards and
assessing the students and the same with
the budget there's very little um change
in that so this summer we'll test out
the P2P model in a summer camp evaluate
and refine it and then try it again in a
um in a after school program and then
after that we can expand it and
implement it on a larger scale
how do you select the students in the
top of the pyramid how do you select the
first four over there so we're looking
at the the analytics that we're
collecting about students what their
interest level is what their past
experiences are what they've really
enjoyed and learning before and have
gone deeper in it and these students
will rotate depending on the content
right so in we're learning about marine
biology and this is a high school class
there might four students that really
surface as the ones that have the
interest and the background knowledge
and the teacher moves them forward and
another content area if we're doing
literature it might be another four
students so everybody gets a chance to
be an expert and our starting group
would be selected by themselves in a
summer program so that they've put
themselves forward for
it wouldn't you actually aren't you
creating levels of categories like first
grade student second and so on because
the last ones actually are going to get
the knowledge on different filters
they'll shift sometimes you're the
teacher sometimes you're the leader
sometimes you're the learn so you have
to shift
anyway and this wouldn't necessarily be
going down in terms of grade level this
might be the same ninth and 10th grade
classroom that is learning different
topics and then it would be um third
grade would also do this and it would be
all third graders learning different
topics and the quality of the teaching
may not be worse on the bottom areas
we're not saying the best students are
necessarily at the top because it be
based on interest and other um
mechanisms so but now you conf confused
me you said those which rise up would
come in the first layer so uh based on
interest and other other things so
they're not necessarily the best
students or the smartest
students okay so so um I'd urge you just
to look at some of the things that have
been done on trying to keep the status
distinctions among students in balance
while you're trying some of these things
that's where the data collection piece
is really key so teachers know who's
already taught three lessons or three
content areas who hasn't ISS like that
to wait until I graduate to do something
important I'm a teacher I want to teach
my students well but I don't know how
and I feel like I don't have the
resources research shows that students
can understand best when they're
actively engaged in Hands-On learning
this is why we want to build a social
network but for Education the delis
Network connects all
stakeholders it allows teachers to
access tutorials made by other teachers
and experts that they can use for
professional development it allows
students to build and share portfolios
that will provide an incentive for them
to be creative and thirdly it allows
donors to uh to access uh the network
and see where which areas their help is
most needed in
when students go into the delas network
they'll see other students they'll see
what other students are making learning
as well as many tutorials um on projects
based learning they would also see so
many solutions on how to um solve
certain things such as public speaking
and other projects when teachers go on
they'll learn the skills they need to do
Project based learning which is a very
select set of skills including growth
mindset how to scaffold a program
project how to set up the classroom they
also be able to see the projects that
other teachers have done and post their
material
needs and when donors access the website
they will be able to see areas where
their help is most needed because every
school has a virtual presence on the
network and every school has a voice to
ask for exactly the sort of resources
that it needs our strategy is to build
the platform and to spread awareness
that way we can go through um the
education system through having
certification programs we can use social
media and advertising in um education
Publications we anticipate that this
would take about 3 to 6 months to build
the actual platform um and then another
6 months to year to build a network
that's really
valuable you so much3 you don't mind
over for your
Des right I'm a teacher and I'm so busy
so many of these resources like why why
am I using this
um and how aming it so one one of the
things about this website is that
there's a very strong presence of
experts um which is another fourth
stakeholder that's connected to this
website that we didn't talk about um the
it's a um we anticipate that it's
actually a designed course so it's not
just a matter of so first they can go
through the course and then they can
access individual tutorials later to to
boost their knowledge um and then the
projects that are posted are curated um
either through a rating system or
through somebody actually on staff
saying that one's not quite good enough
let's get it out of the way so it
doesn't distract
people How does it go beyond the early
adopter teachers to the middle of the
bell curve what do you mean by that um
so they're going to be teachers who have
incredible energy and want to do Project
based learning and will Buck the
administration to do that um but how do
you reach the next quartile of teachers
that's a great question so um if there's
a certification program that goes with
the professional development that's
offered here that can be an incentive so
it can be there's a lot of times there's
professional development um requirements
for teachers and if this is then
certified by the state to be one of the
Like official ways to do that then the
teachers are getting that PD which they
will then enable them to go past that
point of saying I can't do this I don't
have the time to do this because they
have to do professional development and
this would be then one of the ways to
help them actually realize this is
something that's
attainable and in addition if it's
something that they're doing through
their sort of required professional
development piece then they'll also be
exposed to it in terms of um the donor
recognition part so they'll realize that
again this is something that is actually
accessible because this one platform
brings all the pieces how are you going
to get started with the content or with
the social network or how are you just
how are you going to started well as
we're building the platform I think that
will be the um pulling together the
resources and then having to build the
network once we have resources that are
valuable enough to go C all
right our second to last welcome the
team
24 all right so often if you go into a
classroom you'll see a student and they
feel and if you're a teacher and you
look at your class and they all say me
it can get really hard to be excited to
teach them and students feel this way
because they can't see the connections
between what they're studying and the
real world and we want to change that so
that instead they say things like oh or
Aha and that's so cool so how do we do
this how do we bring that passion we are
proposing a launch space which is a
Hands-On space where teachers and
students can work collaboratively on
real world projects and they'll be
really engaged and they'll want to learn
and so what does this space look like it
kind of breathes creativity so you have
tables where you can sit around and have
discussion and conversations and
whiteboards and supplies for ideation
and then you have the tools that you can
build and bring your ideas to life so
students will be coming with their teams
and they'll be really excited because
they're working on projects that relate
to the real world whether it's through
the community or through industry so
instead of a traditional teacher student
model um this space is going to have a
facilitator and this is someone who's
trained in creating a out of the-box
thinking design atmosphere and so
because there's a facilitator um who
will draw from the community from
industry and eventually trained teachers
um the teachers will check their
identity at the door they're going to
become mentors and work with their
students on team projects and they are
working together towards the same goal
and these are projects that are decided
upon collaboratively between a student
and the teacher because this makes sure
that a the students are interested
because they're the ones who propose
these things and B the teachers also
make sure that they accomplish learning
goals that they set out at the beginning
so that these projects will complement
what they're learning in their regular
classes and so deliverables um there of
course be self and peer review but also
very important is to have industry
critiques um people from industry from
outside communities coming in and
critiquing them and this gives them um
accountability and also um G expands
their
worldview
first question for me is um is this
built into the schools or is this a
community program is this out in the
community it's this is a space that
we're going to put into the school build
into so like a extra portable full of
all the cool stuff all the cool stuff
okay yes all
right a portable like like an actual
portable like schools buy the trailers
and they park outside classroom and
there's going to be design space like we
described and then some
tools so it can be adaptable to each
environment so it should we have almost
like a design space where you do the
talking like we did over here and then
you have machine on the other side you
can go but it's more longterm than truck
it's yeah this is this belongs to you
buy owner the
mobile this is like their design
space who pays for it so because we're
going to be working with Community
industry uh we think they will be
interested because they'll have problems
that they propose who they industry yeah
industry Community um but but we think
this is a really cool idea to to make
the connection between the concept that
you learn in the class and bring and
apply to the real world and if it's a
really good idea I think even the
parents or the town should be able to
say okay this is something we need to
adopt so cost shared with Partners
industry Partners University
Partners how does it how do you imagine
it interfaces with what they're normally
doing in school is it you know you take
a block of classes and do it there or
take the learning goals that they have
in their current classes and they'll
adapt it to the projects they're working
on and so it'll be a continuation and a
better way to think about what they're
learning in their normal class and as it
evolves they can use these projects to
then like go back and figure out what is
the best way I can make this project
happen and so it's more applicable right
like as this goes on teachers can like
bring things oh yeah I can like teach
this part of the curriculum in there and
so they can adap they're teaching in
their classes well so there's kind of
like a feedback
and uh so we're H Team 25 um I'm Adia
you're um I'm Denise Mara
and so by the time finished saying the
sentence the students already dropped
out of school that's just
wrong um just let's face it students
like me today aren't engaged with what
schools have to offer for kids they as
Matthew Malone said yesterday they're
teaching the same thing they did quite a
few years ago so we wanted to um Inspire
students um creative instincts their um
intrinsic motivic motiv motivation to
learn yeah so our solution is a cross
disciplinary course prompted by students
Ben loves soccer and chemistry and he's
curious to explore both subjects but he
doesn't know how they are actually
compatible so today in class he received
this form where he's asked what his two
main interests are so he answers and um
get Ben gets spared with two teachers
who get him will guide him through the
known Journey um he'll be also organized
into groups of students with similar
interest so sorry next Friday uh Ben
will be part of mix it up Ben and
classmates that uh are around him with
similar interests will come together and
start working on an independent and
integrative project um this way uh
throughout the semester students will
come up with their own content and
manage their own projects uh with Ben
with the help of his teachers will not
only fulfill existing class competencies
but um also get to uh get to explore his
Natural Curiosity and intrinsic
motivation
so basically what we want to do is we
want to develop the survey that's going
to ask students what they're interested
in what they want to learn about um and
then we're going to create a manual for
a collaboration between the students and
the teachers that they're going to be
working with to develop their own
curriculum um and kind of change the
teacher student relationships that's in
traditional schools and then we're going
to do this
stuff
is this uh PD is this the core of it you
got to get teachers trained to implement
basically it's a Grassroots model um and
so we want to have like mixed up
champions in every school um that teach
their other professionals and teachers
in their school how to how to
collaborate with students and and figure
out what their interest in learning um
so increasing their professional
development but also making it
autonomous within the school
itself uh I don't know the name the
it'll be part of a way of schools to be
like the raise the bar race to the top
race to the top sorry the race to stop
top structure so they will be encouraged
to uh implement this project this system
so that they can race the top and get
more funding ranking
based so it's it's in integrated with
the same course competencies that's
already in the system so even though
it's a new course it's still fulfilling
a lot of the systemic stuff that we
already have to deal with yeah while
giving students autonomy and helping
teachers and students be engaged
together and with a a different
perspective you know yes mixing two
courses that would usually not be put
together and yes um students are
interested in yeah so any other
questions what happens when the uh the
two interests fall out of a purview of a
school or the right so there's there's
another stakeholder that's definitely
the professionals and so when they're
creating this uh this class it's going
to be like before the semester that
they're going to take it in so it's like
what people do we need to contact that
we don't have the resources for and how
do we contact them and who's who's most
appropriate um and and it changes that's
why we survey students every year
because we want to be able to follow the
trends and have real time learning so it
becomes sustainable and always growing
mechanism well thank you everyone
for